Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Me acuerdo de cuando en la secundaria
me enseñaron interés compuesto.
Que si ponías 100 pesos,
al mes siguiente tenías 110;
al mes siguiente, 121; después, 132;
porque se va a acumulando,
los intereses son
sobre los intereses también.
Lo entendí, pero lo que
me partía la cabeza
era el hecho de que
si esperás suficiente tiempo
llegás a niveles que no podías imaginar.
Por ejemplo, a los 10 años,
llegás a casi 10 millones de pesos.
Con solo 100 pesos, sin hacer nada más.
Lo que no me enseñaron en la secundaria
es que en la vida hay muchísimos procesos
en los que no pasa nada,
no pasa nada, no pasa nada,
y de repente pasan un montón de cosas.
Son procesos con diferentes
mecanismos acumulativos
que generan resultados inesperados,
efectos inesperados.
Un ejemplo es las redes de amigos,
redes de contactos,
en donde si pasamos de uno a dos,
tal vez hay un poco más de opciones,
pero si pasamos a tres,
tenemos muchísimas más opciones
de las que creíamos.
Podemos hacer algo con uno,
con el otro, con otro.
Con estos dos, con estos dos.
Con esos dos, con los tres.
Solos.
Cuantos más contactos,
cuantos más amigos tenemos,
se multiplican las opciones.
Lo mismo pasa con el aprendizaje.
Aprendemos una cosa.
Después aprendemos otra que tal vez
no tienen nada que ver entre ellas.
Pero aprendemos una tercera,
y con la tercera vemos un patrón
que nos permite entender
algo nuevo de las otras dos.
Después, hacemos algo nuevo,
probamos algo.
Y nos sale mal.
Pero aprendimos algo más, de vuelta.
Con cada cosa que aprendemos,
con cada patrón,
aprender se hace más fácil.
De esta manera vamos construyendo
un castillo de aprendizaje
que en lugar de agotar nuestra memoria,
nos permite aprender cada vez más.
En todos estos procesos
pasa como en el interés compuesto.
Uno empieza despacito,
despacito, despacito,
pero si tenemos persistencia,
perseverancia
y miramos el largo plazo,
podemos llegar a resultados
que no podíamos imaginarnos.
Puedo tener o no tener dinero
para invertir en interés compuesto.
Pero aprendí que siempre voy a invertir
en mis redes de amigos y de contactos
y nunca pero nunca
voy a dejar de aprender.
(Aplausos)